[Music]
so I am super honored today to be joined
by the cast of impulse the YouTube
original show so Missy my first question
is for you
so you've done so many comedic roles oh
man and this is a very serious role in
this role of Cleo do you find any of
your previous comedic characters in that
character does anything come from any of
those I would say the alien from Galaxy
Quest okay okay thank you
I like that okay and then my next
question is for Maddie
hello Maddie so coming into New York
comic-con
there is a huge banner of you just
outside of this press area right in the
center and you're a younger actors in
this big lead role do you feel more
pressure this season embracing this role
or less in filming season two I felt
less pressure in a in a way because I
knew Henry and it wasn't Godot what are
you doing I'm trying to answer a
question about me he likes that camera
and then but more in a way I don't know
there's always pressure I just want it
to be like the best that it can be yeah
yeah I like that and then Lauren yes
question for you being at the helm of
this thing in this crowded saturated
field of all this TV and streaming what
is your elevator pitch for somebody to
jump into this show and binge season one
and then start to oh man that is a lot
of pressure with a young woman to my
left holding Lauren take away me deeply
don't trust I would say if you're
looking for something that is wildly
different than other shows that you've
seen it's not a traditional genre show
we don't lead with genre it's a small
grounded character story about a
woman at the center she grapples with
and her mother and her mother who's a
genius of an actor with really difficult
situations and we go there and yeah it's
kind of weirdly also a show that deals
with trauma and you kind of don't
anticipate it and we try not to make it
so difficult to watch that you can't
engage but it really is for a lot of
people who've experienced anything like
that and we're trying to give voice for
those people so that would be I guess my
elevator pitch on the elevator would
open yeah and someone would throw me out
what an incredible woman amazing she
steps up to the plate yes and she
teleports Callum you're my closing
question here are your questions this is
my first comedic role my question is for
you
what is your favorite sci-fi film of all
time no I'm not that's no that's five
times I've seen it like I will if it's
on I watch it I went to the cinema I
have another no I have you know what it
cuz it's Syfy but it's also a great
actor movie there's not a lot of movies
about actors that show them in a light
that they're humane gran they have a
soul right like it has some qualities to
it that are like great are you
starstruck by misty ever yes
I love that classic well guys thank you
so much for joining me it was quick and
short but I had so much fun and all my
subscribers please make sure to watch
season 2 of impulse on YouTube October
16th
[Music]